today we're going to be speaking with
kelly weil who's a journalist at the
daily beast where she covers extremism
disinformation and the internet also
author of off the edge flat earthers
conspiracy culture and why people will
believe anything kelly really great to
have you on today
thanks for having me so i i want to get
a little bit to the resurgence of flat
earth specifically because i think it's
an interesting kind of window into a lot
of the the stuff that you cover but if
we zoom out a little bit um you know
when i've spoken to both extremists and
those who cover extremists often they
say that the folks most likely to fall
into these types of beliefs generally
are
folks with
on the one hand certain personality
characteristics but on the other hand
with backgrounds that are often about
not having something that they feel a
sense of belonging towards and sometimes
this relates to parenting sometimes this
relates to communities or bullying in
school or the these sort of types of
things
what's your sense covering this and
researching it about what makes folks
more likely to as you say in the title
of the book believe anything
i mean there are a few factors and one
thing that i have to flag is that we're
all susceptible to conspiratorial
thinking to some degree it's not some
weird thing that tinfoil hat people do
um it really emerges when we feel like
we don't have enough information or the
information we have isn't comforting for
us it doesn't reaffirm our priors but
you're right to bring up that sort of um
sense of isolation because one of the
things that people go looking for when
they seek out flat earth or another
conspiracy theory is a sense of
belonging is a sense of community and
conspiracy theories often work in this
weirdly team-based way uh it becomes
sort of an ups versus them mentality
where you're either on the inside of
this uh small community that says it has
all the answers and the world is out to
get us or you're on the other side and
by definition evil and
scheming so i think those communities
are very alluring for people who both
want community and want answers and it
repackages them in a way that i think is
uh it's it's very appealing for certain
people
the comfort thing is interesting because
one of the one of the characteristics
not not a flat earth specifically but of
some other conspiracy theories including
that
random events were actually planned what
seems to underlie it is that it's really
stressful to think or to believe that
random bad things happen that you
couldn't possibly protect yourself from
and that it's sort of a matter of chance
whether you personally are affected by
something or not it seems that some
people get comfort from believing it was
planned and at least some people knew
exactly when and how this was going to
happen
yeah and it's weird to think what's
comforting for certain people because if
you told me that you know there's a
whole bunch of evil-doers in a dark room
scheming all these events it's actually
the opposite of comforting to me that's
a little distressing but for some people
that's better than the idea of pure
chaos or
they often make it very theological you
know they don't like the idea that
there's nobody looking out for them and
you know to tie this back to flat earth
one of the best
reasonings i've heard for someone
getting into flat earth theory is uh
they believe the earth is like the
universe is very small it's this little
flat earth contained under a snow globe
basically and she said that she didn't
like the idea that the universe was so
big and so random and that she was this
little point in it and when she
compressed all the
unknown knowns into this again really
small
um
snow globe
that she realized that she was special
and she had a place in the universe and
so i think that explains a little bit of
it you you write about how there was
actually a flat earth movement in the
1830s
and um i think many people might just
say well you know we just knew a lot
less then but but actually 1830 was not
the start of when we started to realize
that
the spherical earth is actually what it
is can you talk a little bit about kind
of what led that movement and what the
beliefs were based on
totally so you're right i mean we've
known for more than two thousand years
now that earth is round and it's because
it's actually pretty easy to prove
old-timey mathematicians in greece and
egypt were doing this for ages
what happened in the 1830s 1840s
was it was a time of upheaval it was a
time of technological and scientific
uh revolution and that is a moment when
people go looking for alternative
answers and
as new ideas of science and evolution
were forcing religion to take the back
seat
in a lot of people's minds people
started looking for reasons to discount
science and flat earth emerged from this
really uh wacky character he was a
failed commune leader he
sold
fake medical cures for a while he had
this theory that because earth looks
flat it must be flat and not only that
but it's um
that scientists are actively colluding
to hide the reality from you so for
people who wanted to opt out of new
fields of science this was the golden
ticket
right and when we think about the
resurgence of flat earth like over the
last six to ten years
it's interesting that we have so many
more technological means available to us
now and so many different ways to to
easily prove that the earth is not flat
and yet it it has still resurged but on
a sort of different basis right
absolutely you know um
it's funny for about 200 years now
we've been
watching flat earthers come up with new
reasons to discard new scientific
evidence
in the
during the space phrase flat earthers
had to contend with okay why are there
pictures of earth from outside earth if
we're all underneath this snow globe um
and increasingly i'm seeing people
not um
really try to contend with the evidence
at all but say that any new conflicting
evidence is
actually proof of a scheme against them
it's uh it's fabricated it's uh there to
deceive them
so
one thing is that this theory and many
other conspiracy theories are not really
about the provability or the
believability they're about people's
willingness to
believe against all odds and when you
get that kind of motivated reasoning it
becomes really easy to just chuck out
evidence that you don't like you know in
the past when when i've interviewed
experts on conspiracism and
conspiratorial thinking often we kind of
start from the point of flat earth being
one of the most benign
non-empirically based sort of
conspiratorial beliefs and that it might
exist in a sort of isolated benign space
but many of these folks who who study
this say well
rarely do people just have one of these
beliefs and so there's really more than
random overlap between like flat earth
beliefs
illuminati one world government
anti-semitic beliefs you know that that
all these different things are linked
more than you would expect by random
chance and so while flat earth
specifically might sort of be benign
it's often
the same types of folks that go to the
flat earth conferences that are that are
doing some of the other stuff do you do
you agree with that assessment disagree
with it partially agree
i absolutely agree and i think it's
getting worse too um i started
following flat earth around 2017 and
even at that time i thought it was a
little bit more siloed i didn't see so
much interchange with other conspiracy
theories whereas now i see a lot more
active networking what would have been
uh purely flat earth facebook page 2017
is now sharing a lot of kobe disciple or
uh thinly veiled q anon and
you know it does make sense in a way
because if you believe in something so
literally world encompassing as flat
earth
you're not going to believe that every
other established reality holds true you
know flat earth lets you just knock down
all the facts and build your own and so
it's very easy for people to draw on
pre-existing conspiracy theories and
you're right to note that a lot are
anti-semitic or hateful in nature one of
the interesting things about flat earth
is there's there's this kind of common
belief which i think is borne out by the
studies which is
you can't just give facts to folks who
believe certain things and and sometimes
the more facts you give them the more
they actually resist changing their
perspective and the interesting thing in
that context about flat earth is
that
the they have rebuttals to just about
every purported rebuttals i think i
should say to just about every empirical
claim that you can present to them with
data and with facts and and with
observation and so it's sort of like the
perfect um
experiment as to what does get folks to
revise their beliefs when it comes to
people who were flat earthers
but were disabused of those beliefs what
has worked effectively
what has worked with the ex-flat
earthers that i've spoken to
is not exactly debate because i think
when people debate they dig into their
own
beliefs they
double down they don't want to be proven
wrong
what i've found has helped in the
limited cases of
d conversions because i think people
need to be willing to deconvert
is they've had compassionate discussions
with round authors people who aren't
here to belittle them or prove them
wrong or have one of these awful uh
youtube livestream debates but say okay
why
did you come to this belief and
you know what emotionally is motivating
you to do this and
um
what can we do that's observable to you
you know can we go watch the sunset over
the horizon will that help um and that
kind of compassionate exchange one that
you know takes into account the humanity
of the person that you're trying to talk
to and the emotional needs that drive
them to conspiracy theories often i
think is a lot more fruitful than this
um
this belittling or
i keep using the term team based but
it's
conspiracy theories are very team based
and if you turn it into an us versus
them debate
it follows that that's not going to
convert somebody
what are the um motives that flat
earthers believe
explain why the powers that be so to
speak would want
folks believing that the earth is
actually spherical when it's flat
that's a really tough one and it's one
that i ask a lot of flat earthers and i
get a range of answers and quite a lot
of people say i don't really know
um i mean the upsetting answer is a lot
of people will say something pretty
anti-semitic right or they'll use a
million even though like why would the
jews benefit from the earth really being
flat but people thinking it's spherical
like i don't even know right right i
mean you know it just it
none of these theories because they're
you know it goes back and it's building
on centuries of
uh conspiratorial frameworks none of
them actually hold up there's no reason
a religious group would want to
disguise the earth's shape but you know
they'll they'll make those call backs or
they'll use something a bit more veiled
the illuminati the new world order
they'll say that um maybe
we uh that the powers that be wants you
downplay the role of religion in the
world or they want to keep people
confused or the best dancer i ever got
was this guy so flat earthers generally
don't believe in outer space
and this guy is like well what i think
is going on is they want us to believe
in space so they want us to believe in
aliens so that when jesus comes down
again we'll think he's an alien and
we'll kill him so
that's that's pretty tough to talk
someone out of i mean that's the crazy
thing about it
oh that was really rough because i mean
he clearly thought about this for much
longer than i was ever going to yeah um
but the long and short of it is people
are really willing to believe this
theory and sometimes the specifics or
even the motivation comes secondary
can you talk a little bit about um the
social media platform algorithms like on
facebook and youtube and specifically
like with flat i think many in my
audience generally understand uh
controversy does better algorithmically
so then in general platforms will share
articles that are
negative divisive etc with no regard for
whether they are accurate or not but
what what are we seeing about these
algorithms specifically with flat earth
flat earth has performed really really
well historically in social media
algorithms especially on youtube there's
a period from about 2014 to 2019 when
flat earth videos got this massive
artificial boost and the reason is i
mean youtube is a company they want to
make money and they make money from you
staying on the site watching videos
um and so because
flat earth was something that i'm guilty
of this too everybody clicks on it two
in the morning um those videos perform
very well algorithmically and people
would get recommended to them even if
they weren't seeking them out so
youtube did change its algorithm after
tons of criticism by 2019 but the fact
still stands for five years this was a
really just like open fire hose of flat
earth info into unsuspecting people's
speeds
uh last thing i wanted to talk about can
you talk a little bit about in the in
the culture in the landscape right now
of conspiracy theories and and sort of
extremist beliefs what are maybe some
less known things that are maybe coming
up i mean i think q anon my audience
knows about flat earth election was
stolen vaccines are killing millions but
nobody you know
some of the obvious ones i think my
audience is aware of but is there
anything kind of like up and coming that
you're tracking
oh man um
the question is always like whether to
talk about it if it's up and coming
right um you know i think
to put it a different way i mean there
are always fringe theories on the up
what i think is different now is the um
their embrace in uh mainstream
republican politics so whereas cuna was
something that was you know on its face
completely absurd and deranged um now
we're seeing this much more
uh wholesale embrace of things like
election conspiracy theories by the
republican party and you know as much as
i
will criticize things for like social
media for their role in promoting
conspiracy theories this i think is
uncharted or
not recently charted territory you mean
the degree to which the republican party
has participated
exactly the um their role in promoting
it and the role in normalizing it and i
think that is pretty dangerous and
as much as you know we can
rail on the youtubes and the facebooks
for promoting this info
this is an integral part of american
politics and it is just diving all the
way in on conspiracy theories do you
have an opinion as to for how long will
they continue with the evidence is just
about to come out i mean because it's
we're at 15 months now and rudy giuliani
and trump and i mean they continue to
say
we're we're about to get the stuff from
georgia we're about to get the stuff
from america will does this have a long
life ahead of it you think
i think it does but not because they're
going to keep claiming the evidence is
coming out
it's like flat earth where the evidence
doesn't really matter it's an emotional
appeal right so after they see this
narrative for so long it doesn't really
matter that they keep getting disproven
because people believe it there's enough
of this saturation of the story that
people want to believe and
by that point they'll have already you
know
taken down uh voting sites in
predominantly black neighborhoods
they'll already have passed legislation
that makes it difficult to send in
absentee ballots and that i think is
like the real tangible risk of this
conspiracy theorizing is it enables
things that are very real yeah at this
point it's almost like they're signaling
their membership in a team by repeating
that rather than we literally are
waiting around for the evidence
totally yeah if only they were waiting
around because i mean they'll be doing
that until they die for a very long time
yeah uh kelly weil is a journalist at
the daily beast the book is off the edge
flat earthers conspiracy culture and why
people will believe anything kelly
really appreciate your time
thanks for having me